الكثير من الإثارة الترقب
والأسئلة المحيطة بالأخبار التي تفيد بأن
لقاحين على الأقل وربما ثلاثة
لقاحات لفيروس كورونا يمكن أن يكون في طريقهم قريبًا.
سؤال واحد لدى الناس هو هل ستكون
توصيات لقاح الفيروس التاجي
مشابهة للقاح الإنفلونزا إذا
حصلت عليه إذا كنت لا تشعر بذلك  حسنًا
أو وازن يشرح الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا
سبب
إخبارك عادةً بعدم الحصول على
لقاح الإنفلونزا إذا لم تكن على ما يرام
هو
أن الطريقة التي تعمل بها هذه اللقاحات هي
أنها تزيد نوعًا ما من
نظام المناعة لديك إذا كان نظام المناعة لديك  مشغول بالفعل في
محاربة شيء آخر ، فقد لا
يستجيب كذلك أو
قد لا تشعر
أنك على ما يرام إذا لم تظهر عليك أعراض ،
يجب أن تمضي قدمًا وتشعر بالراحة في
الحصول على اللقاح عندما يحين
دورك وماذا عن متطلبات التخزين
لأحد  من بين تلك اللقاحات ،
كيف سنعرف أنه تم الاحتفاظ بها في
درجة حرارة منخفضة مناسبة حتى
نقطة الحقن ،
ما تفعله شركة فايزر هو أنها تصنع زميلاتها
الخاصة  صناديق تخزين ld
ستكون هناك هذه الصناديق التي تراها
ستأخذك تعرف آلاف
جرعات اللقاح وهذا ما
سيتم استخدامه للنقل داخل
هذه الصناديق سيكون أيضًا أجهزة الاستشعار
التي تخبرك  كانت درجة الحرارة
متسقة هل كان هناك أي انخفاضات
وتأكد من أن اللقاحات على الأقل
من وجهة النظر هذه لم تواجه أي
مشاكل ،
يذكرنا الدكتور غوبتا أنه مع
جهود التطعيم العالمية هذه ،
سيكون هناك الكثير من الخطوات والفحوصات
على طول الطريق من
أجل صحة اليوم  دقيقة أنا ريد بيدن ،
هذا يوم تاريخي يوم تاريخي
للعلم وبالنسبة لنا جميعًا ،
ألبرت بورلا هو الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركة فايزر ويتحدث عن لقاحهم لـ covid19
248 يومًا من الفكرة
إلى الآن التقدم بطلب للحصول على اللقاح ليتم
التصريح
بذلك.  ثمانية أشهر فقط للسياق
كان يمكن اعتبار ثماني سنوات
سريعة
ولكن الحقيقة هي أن القصة التي أنا على وشك أن
أخبرك بها بدأت بالفعل منذ
أكثر من عقدين من الزمن وفهمها حقًا
عليك أولاً أن تفهم كيف
تعمل معظم اللقاحات
منذ اللقاح الأول
للجدري في عام 1796
، فقد اعتمدوا جميعًا على نفس المفهوم الأساسي ،
أعطوا قطعة صغيرة من الفيروس
المعروف أيضًا باسم المستضد لشخص
لا يكفي لإصابته بالمرض
وجسمه  سيتم بعد ذلك تعليم
كيفية صنع أجسام مضادة لها ، تلك هي
البروتينات التي تعمل على تحييد الفيروس
إذا حاول الغزو مرة أخرى ، وهذا
ما يجعلك محصنًا ،
ولكن ماذا لو كان يمكن تعليم الجسم
القيام بكل شيء
ليس فقط صنع الأجسام المضادة ولكن أيضًا
لصنع
أصبحت المستضدات أيضًا آلة صنع اللقاح الخاصة
بها ، ولهذا السبب في العقد الأول من القرن الحالي ، بدأ رسم ويسمان في
التركيز على هذه السلسلة الصغيرة من
المواد الجينية
التي تجعلها خلايانا طوال الوقت
تُعرف باسم mrna في
ذلك الوقت كنا نفكر في استخدامها
للقاحات
بالنسبة للبروتينات العلاجية لتحرير الجينات
للعديد من التطبيقات المختلفة mrna
تعني mrna أنها تحمل
التعليمات لصنع أي بروتين
تريده مرة واحدة.  لقد حصلت على التسلسل ،
إنه رد فعل من خطوة واحدة لعمل
rna وهذا التفاعل مطابق لكل
لقاح نصنعه
إذا كان هذا يبدو أشبه بكود في
جهاز كمبيوتر بدلاً من دواء من مختبر ،
فهذا يعني أنك تحصل عليه هذا هو
طريقة جديدة تمامًا للتفكير في
اللقاحات ،
إنها أيضًا التقنية الأساسية وراء
لقاحات شركة فايزر ولقاحات Modernis covid19
قريبة من قدومها ، كما
تعلم ، قلت إن المساعدة على الطريقة
التي تلتقي بها الحيوية حقًا مع
التكنولوجيا ، فاللقاح ليس فيروسًا على الإطلاق
في الأساس
مجرد رمز جيني لجزء من
الفيروس ،
هذا الجزء هو بروتين سبايك ، سبب وجود
بروتين سبايك
لأنه المفتاح الذي يستخدمه الفيروس
لدخول الخلية البشرية ،
ولكن إذا قمت بإنشاء أجسام مضادة
لبروتين السنبلة
، فسيتم حظرها ، لذا ضعها معًا
مرة واحدة  يتم إعطاء اللقاح المكون من الشفرة الجينية من
خلال حقنة في
الذراع ،
ثم تبدأ خلايانا في صنع
بروتين السنبلة
مرارًا وتكرارًا ، تذكر الآن
أنك تصنع جزءًا من الفيروس
لذلك لا يمكن أن تصاب بالعدوى من هذا
اللقاح
وفي غضون أيام بعد ذلك
يتفاعل الجسم ويبدأ في إخراج سدادة الأجسام المضادة
واللعب مع rna ، كل ما تحتاجه هو
تسلسل البروتين المطلوب في غضون أسابيع ،
يمكنك الحصول على لقاح جديد ،
إنه  التكنولوجيا التي يمكن أن
تساعدنا في الخروج من هذا الوباء ،
سنحصل على الكثير من
المساعدة من لقاح فعال للغاية
لقاحين كانا قبل أسبوعين فقط
وفي الأسبوع الماضي ، فعالين
للغاية ،
أعني أنه فعال في  95
و 94.5 في المائة إذا كانت
النتائج رائعة حقًا لنوع جديد تمامًا
من
اللقاح وأيضًا طريقة جديدة للتفكير في
الأدوية التي تمضي قدمًا
لتشهد نقصًا كبيرًا في إمدادات
اللقاحات على مدار
الأشهر الستة المقبلة وسيكون هناك
اندفاع مجنون
بالنسبة لهم  وأملنا وهدفنا
كشراكة من وكوفاكس بين غارفي وسيبي ومن
نأمل أن نتمكن من تحقيق
الوصول العادل ، فنحن قادرون على الحصول على دعم
كاف
مهما كان عدد اللقاحات
نحن متاحون ونأمل أن نتمكن من
توزيعها في جميع
أنحاء العالم حتى نتمكن من حماية أولئك الذين
هم في الخطوط الأمامية والأكثر
ضعفًا
والذين يحتاجون إلى الحماية العاجلة بدلاً
من أن تعرف تطعيم
مجموعات سكانية بأكملها في بعض البلدان
بينما ينتظر الجميع
هذا هو ما نعمل من أجله
ونأمل حقًا أن نتمكن من القيام بذلك
الآن مهما كانت هذه الظروف
، سيستغرق الأمر عامًا حتى نبدأ
في تغطية
15 إلى 20 بالمائة من سكان العالم
إذا أخذتم العالم بأسره
وأننا نعتقد أنه يجب أن يكون 20
شخصًا هم الأشخاص الأكثر تعرضًا لخطر
الإصابة بالعدوى أو الموت
، يجب منحهم
الأولوية ، فقط في عام 2022 يمكننا أن نبدأ في
رؤية برنامج تطعيم أوسع بكثير